do you think labor should now become a
remain and Reform Party well the short
answer to that is that it should be a
referendum remain and Reform Party
Labour's problem is not Alastair
Campbell
I mean Labour's problem is that its
position on your on the European
question the defining question for
Britain at the moment is completely
unclear and while its position is
unclear it's not going to be able to
offer the country the kind of leadership
it needs remember we've got the most
unpopular government that I can remember
in 20 or 30 years following politics and
labour has shown itself or the Labour
leadership has shown itself completely
unable to take advantage of that to
offer the country a clear path forward
and I think that there is now thankfully
a thoroughgoing an open debate happening
in the labour party about how to
properly address this question was it
hasn't done so over the last three years
and I just wonder I mean did you vote
labour in the European evoke by proxy
labour in the European elections
I did actually I did vote labour I vote
by postal vote not by proxy but I did
vote labour because the two candidates
standing in the constituency in the
central London constituency Claude
morass and Seb dance are excellent
members of the European Parliament and
they've got very principled and I think
appropriately proactive and sensible
views on how to resolve the briggsie
crisis
this isn't about neglecting lis voters
or refusing to listen to leave voters
after all South Shields my former
constituency voted leave it's about
offering those voters the choice and the
truth which is that they voted on the
principle of brexit three years ago and
it's only right that they get the chance
to vote on the detailed practicalities
of what brigs it now involves and I
think that commitment to offer choice to
people and democratic choice is the
right thing to do for the political
stability to for the country and it's
also the right thing to do for the
economic and social future of the
country yeah I mean jeremy corbyn's
moving towards maybe a deal a vote
rather on a on a deal approved by
Parliament but you want another remain
or leave referendum
well I think it's imperative that there
is a clear choice between the Briggs it
that people are being offered and the
option of remaining it's not a rerun of
the 2016 referendum because that was a
vote on the principle with no detail at
all no plan at all about what Briggs it
means now I haven't had a chance to
catch up with what Jeremy Corbyn has
said today but on my way in here someone
said to me that he'd made it more
confusing because he talked about not
having a remain option on the ballot the
truth is that when you buy a house you
have a survey done you put down an offer
but you have a survey done if the survey
shows that the house has got subsidence
you're able to say no I don't want to go
ahead and we should give the British
people the chance to decide whether or
not they want to go ahead with the
brexit move as it is now detailed and
obviously we need a government because
there is no government in the UK at the
moment pending the conservative
leadership election but a healthy
democracy needs a strong opposition as
well and that's what I'd like to see
okay just two final questions one I mean
how do you feel being a member of a
party facing an investigation into the
way some Jews appear to have been
victimized within the labour party
absolutely sick obviously I never
believed I would live to see the day
when the words anti-semitism and labor
were in the same sentence or headline
never mind
that the party had been brought into
such disrepute by some of its members
that there should be an investigation by
an anti-discrimination body I think it's
very welcome that there is going to be a
proper engagement with this but the
straightforward answer to your question
is I feel absolutely sick
and the fact that people might like me
who've been a member of the Labour Party
now for 35 37 years should even be
thinking a whether or not we should vote
lay but as I say I did vote labour but
the fact that we should even be
considering it because of the failure on
Briggs it was the failure on
anti-semitism shows you what a terrible
pass we've come to write and are you
going to come back and return to the
fray at what is a very critical time for
the Labour Party
well I'm obviously not a member of
parliament there are big
responsibilities on Member of Parliament
moves apart at the moment but I'm a
British citizen I'm Anna and I'm a
member of the Labour Party and I'll try
and use my voice in whatever way I can
I feel very privileged to have a job
that allows me to lead an NGO and
non-governmental organization that is
doing humanitarian work in 40 countries
there are 13 thousand people working for
the International Rescue Committee today
looking to me for me to be focused on
their concerns and I have to make sure
that in my professional life I focus on
making the most difference for some of
the most vulnerable people in the world
but obviously in my private time I want
to express my views about the fate and
the future of the country as well as the
fate in the future of the party